house goombas - fear to pass this is the
last of the last of the last episode
let's freakin do this Bros oh I remember
this plot twist it was all a dream
what happened
it's just a bad dream sweet pea
Oh
I was a really bad gene what was it
about what da hell he's bit we don't
know how this works here oh yeah it's
like a cold
his mom's a doctor maybe she can help
him I was a kid I never got sick but my
brother always had something maybe we
just gotta hope for the best
not too many other options
I feel bad
why I called him a crybaby when I hit
the bug in his pillow oh that's okay
honey he didn't mean it
we mmm
why did Lily do that to Carly
I don't know
she was sad Glenn I can make people
angry sometimes
have you ever been that angry oh yeah he
has
clam people don't always make sense how
come as bad things happen to everyone
and it's hard to keep being yourself
after they do
do you think we should have let Lily
stay
maybe
it was a hard thing to do I don't think
so she done something to hurt you
I don't know if we did the right thing
how can you tell
well it's not like math clea sometimes
it just isn't the right answer I hate
math huh me too sweet pea part of
growing up is doing what's best for the
people you care about even if sometimes
that means hurting someone else I don't
want to hurt anyone
it's not that easy
I'm scared Lee what can I do you to make
it better
but it'll be okay
it will is gonna get better clean you'll
make it better
everything's gonna be alright
but let's try to get some sleep
okay Lee
Jesus on the left
odo
shut up
she's awake
hey you clam oh thank god you passed out
from the shock what happened that piece
of [ __ ]
rusty shot you we had to run the truck
to keep you warm how do you feel it
hurts
couldn't find the bullet must have gone
clean through it'll burn awhile but
you'll be fine though really geez I mean
I expected it from the Russian but Mike
I could tell they were working on
something I didn't think they'd go that
far yeah well who would steal our food
and shoot a kid he never should have
thrown in with trash like that in the
first place
I can't believe they did that I don't
think they knew what they were doing
except trying to get away yeah well
they're gone now
good [ __ ] riddance now that Clem's
awake we should talk about where we're
going we're headed north what to find
Wellington you sure talk a lot of [ __ ]
but you got a better plan we head south
back to house we can't just head Saab
straight away the [ __ ] kind of plan is
that I think Bonnie said there was more
formula back there and we actually know
where it is I don't care where we go
just please stop arguing she's the one
that's going off because you won't
listen to a thing I'm saying what's that
you're talking into my bad ear
sweetheart
jackass oh I still can't hear you look
even if there is someplace up here it
could take us weeks to find it we could
get back to house in a day tell you what
we can turn around just as soon as you
pry this wheel from a cold dead fingers
how's that sin whatever I give up
get your feet off the dash Tisa's let's
play game Clem I spy with my little eye
an [ __ ] your turn
grow up go to hell I'll pull this
[ __ ] car overhead you want to die out
here you're both being children me I
couldn't see the damn road that you're
having trouble seeing a lot of things
these days you shut your [ __ ] mouth I
am done playing games with you Jay [ __ ]
you you don't know a damn thing about me
oh I know exactly what you I think I
know where this is going but he cares
about you and you don't care about
nobody but yourself
that makes you know what is it with you
it's your family right it is isn't it
I'm warning you you little [ __ ] you just
another type-a [ __ ] trying to save a
bunch of dead people watch the road
I am god damn it you listen to me you
mouth off about my family and I will
[ __ ] end you Jesus Christ I'm so sick
of this wounded warrior crap just pull
over I can't take this what running away
again
what a [ __ ] shocker in the end still
only care about yourself right and where
were you when Sarita died Kenny huh
where were you I was there I couldn't
goddamn you I loved that woman who could
love you look at you you can't raise
this kid it's scared to death of you
I got this way saving your ass from that
hellhole and I would have left you to
rot if I'd known what you were nobody
who died is anyone's fault we we all
wanted to be together and it just went
back but we owe it to them to try to
make the best of this I'm sorry yeah but
I can't put up with this [ __ ]
anymore well the feeling's mutual you
know the thing about people like you
Kenny
you're just a bomb waiting to go off
everyone talks about you behind your
back because they're afraid of you
that ain't Mike bonny Sarita
[ __ ] liar that ain't true everyone
around you knows that sooner or later
they're gonna end up dead
Sarita knew it I know it and so does
Clementine I told you not to talk about
my father you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] hell
you son of a [ __ ]
Jesus oh [ __ ]
you okay I'm fine
how's AJ he's fine you sure yes clamp
you all right yeah Kenny I'm wait hold
on go around one of them might have
diesel we shouldn't stop here we're
running on fumes got no choice when a
holler it's okay
drive up closer anything happens I'll
try to meet you there
all right if you're going go now Kenny
oh I guess not [ __ ] [ __ ] god I
can't do this anymore
I'm serious clam I tried but I just
can't stop making him mad everything
makes him mad
how are you not seeing that no you're
doing is just making it worse you're
just like him clam we could leave right
now are you serious what about AJ look I
know you're close to him but Kenny would
never let him go this is her chance Clem
don't you ever want to know what it's
like to live your own life uh-oh
it's snowing why are they moving they
must not be cold enough yet
[ __ ] get us out of here I don't know how
to drive see that pedal on the floor
step on it don't just sit it's an
automatic car
Oh God
I can't how much worse is it gonna get
she just went on for the baby
oh my how did they Oh Jane oh my god
it's a
she's avoided right now God
where is she
where the is she
Oh dawn what is gonna happen
Rose I don't even look like Bonnie
this episode has been so intense I don't
even know where to begin where are we
going in the right way here oh Jesus
scare me speak
he's strong climbing clue
I'm with the clam I'm with you
I can do this
it's got to be strong
don't cry climb it's gonna be okay it's
gonna be okay
this a shop here
playground
can't tell if this is sad or horror
music could go either way honestly oh
it's open what do you know Jane
no it's Kenny you all right yeah where
is he where's the kid he's left him with
her Jane
Jay why would she just take the baby
like that is there something there oh
she oh thank Christ she doesn't have the
baby Jane she doesn't have the [ __ ]
baby where's the kid where the [ __ ] it's
the kid
oh he's gonna lose it now what did you
do
he's no what are you saying no no
not again not again
look at me
no matter what happens stay out of it
okay just trust me climb Stan um what
you have to trust me you're gonna see
what he really is
how did you lose the [ __ ] baby just
run get out of here
Gleb now get out of my way Kenny I won't
back down from you shut up I'm warning
you Kenny let her talk dumb talking clam
Clem stay back oh my god
don't you come near me
for [ __ ] sake Jason jacked
just go ain't going nowhere
psycho this is on you
I guess shut up
are you okay yeah yeah I think so
clam
you made the right choice
I'll let you down I'll let everyone down
we almost made it
we were close are we
I thought I wanted this passport so many
times now that has happened I'm scared
I'm afraid Glenn it's okay Kenny you
you're going to see kuchen duck you're
going to see them again
oh here always good for a smile
let's [ __ ] [ __ ] again
come on
are you serious
are you okay
he's alive I understand if you're upset
AJ was never in any danger he was just
going to try to talk you into coming
with me I just thought if you saw Kenny
like that you'd know we'd have to leave
him
look Clem I'm sorry I didn't think Kenny
would go that far she knew exactly he
would go that far
how could you do this I had to do it
Glen you saw how he reacted I had to
show you what he was capable of so you
put AJ in danger I got my friend killed
just to prove a point it was a stupid
plan I could never have lied to you but
I thought it was the only way you'd see
oh my god Kenny you have to forgive me
please
I could just leave all this behind us
Kenny this is on me I did it for you
Clem for us I'm not going anywhere with
you Clem please
I did this for you
I can't do this alone okay is that what
you were gonna hear
Clem
my god
goddammit I don't even know what
happened he did started didn't now we're
here
and we left off or we begun
wasn't that hatchet no good oh she's
stronger on their own
even the baby oh my god
I really I really feel like we made
their right choice I don't know if
someone's gonna disagree with me but I
just felt like andis time was over he's
been through so much [ __ ] [ __ ] that
it would wouldn't be a point to keep him
alive and he just needed to see it in
that's why I did it
and the game really forced you to do it
and that's why it was so hard to do it I
feel like I didn't really care much for
the girl I I don't know I just thought
she was kind of an [ __ ] and
especially that she did that just to
prove a point when she said don't
interfere when you see him she knew
exactly what she was doing like that
wasn't it that was this [ __ ] that
she didn't know what she was doing
so it's why I left her
they did it again huh they [ __ ] did
it again when when I remember when
episode 1 and 2 started it start off
kind of slow and I was like rolled
Clem's doing all this weird [ __ ] all the
sudden I wasn't really filling it that
much with episode through you and built
up and then built up to episode 4 which
build up to episode 5 and episode 5 was
just like at dam the fields there was
goddamn peels
ah I honestly did not expect this I I
thought for sure the field train
wouldn't come this time around but it
did and that damn it came hard god damn
it and I'm faith
they defame faith
I don't know what else to say to be
honest
sister
a lot of stuff going on in my head
everyone just [ __ ] died what happened
to Barney and their black guy I don't
remember his name
oh my god oh my god I don't even know
anymore Brad what a meet the Winnie well
I guess that means it's gonna be a
season three
last time they showed the Clementine
part after the credits I want to check
to see if there's anything hiding
they're so embarrassing I feel so
embarrassed I don't know why I doubt it
before I just didn't expect that
you
I really like Kenny I really liked him
from beginning and just I was good in
but so sad now it doesn't look like
there's anything behind the credits this
time around well I'm just gonna go and
do nothing I guess
thank you for this for watching this
series with me it's really an amazing
journey to be sharing with you bros an
amazing experience these games are just
incredible and and I want to thank you
for making it possible for me to do this
I really appreciate it
you're relaxed and your comments always
help and thanks for being a bro
I'll see you bros in the next one stay
awesome hope you okay Brophy